hey guys Ryan the righteousness over
here as Jerry figures out how to drive a
car that was not a double lane you were
wrong once again cheering three strikes
man's a long week wake up early tomorrow
Veronica's there and luggage is there
because we're going on a special trip
and I didn't want to give it away I'm
not going to tell you where we're going
but on Sunday you'll find out when I
will already be there what I will say is
this follow me on you now it's this new
app it's not like I'm doing product
placement follow me on you now right
right now it's prime placement for you
its proper placement for me because I'm
gonna be doing a special Q&A with a very
special guest you guys are gonna want to
tune in for this it's a very very very
special guest biggest guests ever had on
the channel and all you people know who
this person is male or female maybe
you're gonna get away conant why don't
you guys tell me where you think I'm
going and who you think I'm gonna be
collabing with just let's let's do this
let's start spreading rumors okay all
right guys subscribe to the real rejects
if you this is the only video you've
come across this is how little of
content my videos have